und es ist der siebte tag jetzt im
prozess von johnny depp gegen dessen und
nachdem die ex frau des hollywoodstars
amber heard jetzt lange versucht hat ihn
unter anderem als alkoholiker ein mann
mit drogenproblemen und auch vier von
häuslicher gewalt berichtet hat und ein
schlechtes licht geschoben hat gab heute
dann jemand anders einstecken vor
gericht ab und zwar die ex-freundin von
johnny depp winona ryder stand heute vor
gericht um eine kollegin annika rasch
ist in london und weiß wie dieser tag
vor gericht genau ablief ja hallo nele
der die aussage von winona ryder wurde
tatsächlich verschoben
quasi in letzter minute also man hat
wirklich gewartet bis halb fünf also
halb sechs deutscher zeit das winona
ryder hier aus sagt hat sie dann aber
nicht gemacht es gab wohl technische
probleme das ist er jetzt die gestand
woran ist letztendlich lag weiß man
nicht ausgesagt hat aber banking der war
ja lange zeit der haus manager von
johnny depp unter anderem auch in
australien als johnny depp fluch der
karibik gedreht hat und war derjenige
der johnny depps abgetrennte finger
gruppe gefunden hat nach einem streit
mit amber heard da soll sie eine
wodkaflasche anderen mit einer
wodkaflasche seine fingerkuppen
abgetrennt haben und er hat eben die
gefunden und hat dann auch so ein
bisschen das verhältnis der beiden
beschriebenen hat gesagt dass die immer
wie schulkinder gestritten hätten und
amber heard johnny depp immer wieder
provoziert hätte und darauf gewartet
hätte dass er praktisch an die decke
geht aber er hat nie gesehen dass johnny
depp handgreiflich geworden ist und das
soll eben auch ein reiter aussagen und
man rechnet jetzt damit dass es entweder
morgen dabei sein wird und man dann
vanessa paradis die zweite ex freundin
auf freitag verschiebt oder dass man
beide morgen zu wort kommen lässt
morgen also ein weiterer spannender tag
vor gericht dann die hirten die
britische presse jetzt mit diesem
prozess um immerhin ist es johnny depp
gegen ein ja man muss sagen
klatschmagazin sozusagen genau da sollte
man auf jeden fall die sun selbst
erwähnen denn die sun rückt natürlich
nicht von ihren vorwürfen ab nennt
johnny depp weiterhin ein frauenschläger
und ich stehe jetzt hier gerade auch vor
dem verlag mitten in london und das ist
die heutige schlagzeile der sun auch da
titeln sie eigentlich nur das schlechte
über johnny depp sagen dass er im bad
auf deren gemeinsamen honeymoon reise
nach der hochzeit wiederholt geschlagen
hätte das haben sie alles aus auszügen
aus ihren tagebüchern und erwähnt mit
keinem wort die gegnerische stimme und
weichen auch in dem artikel
weiter hinten im blatt nicht davon ab
dass johnny depp ein frauenschläger sei
und über diese ganze über diese ganze
dramatik dieses falls hier in london
habe ich gesprochen mit matthew reid er
hat ehemals mal bei das an gearbeitet
und gilt als die reporter-legende im
showbusiness hier in london
und da wollen wir jetzt mal reinhören so
ein prozess haben wir großbritannien
noch nicht erlebt und ich habe meine
karriere im showbusiness im jahr 1991
gestartet
ich kann mich an keinen fall erinnern
den solch berühmte prominente und
schlüpfrige und abscheuliche details
involviert waren in den jahren seit 1991
habe ich so etwas noch nicht erlebt wenn
wir aber zurück blicken in die 80er
jahre
da war dies an involviert in einem
rechtsstreit mit zur elton john
das war ein übler prozess es war ein
promi gegen eine zeitung hier ist es
aber noch eine dritte seite also noch
eine prominente involviert es ist eine
ganz außergewöhnliche situation und wir
sehen warum ich glaube für keinen sieht
es gerade sonderlich gut aus der andere
preis den er zahlen wird ist dass man
ihm die vorwürfe nicht vergessen wird
wie etwa bei harvey weinstein und der
mito debatte
die nachwirkungen steen war so gewaltig
und das schon bevor er verurteilt wurde
ich denke wenn johnny depp diesem fall
verliert und als frauenschläger gilt
dann wird keine hochrangige
produktionsfirma mehr mit ihm arbeiten
vor ein paar jahren wäre das anders
gewesen aber nachdem mainz den prozess
hat sich das komplett geändert kein
studio keine angesehene rolle wird firma
wird jemals wieder mit jemandem arbeiten
der seine frau geschlagen hat